انتظار اطول من المعتاد للحصول على هاتفي
ايفون 14 برو ايفون 14 بروماكس احدث نسخه
من ايفون شركه ابل الامريكيه قالت ان موقع
انتاج هواتف ايفون الرئيسي في مدينه تينغ
شو بوسط الصين يعمل حاليا بقدره منخفضه
بشكل كبير وذلك منذ اكتشاف اصابات بيكوزيت
في صفوف عماله البالغ عددهم اكثر من
200,000
سيتعين على الزبائن للانتظار لفتره اطول
لاستلام المنتجاتهم الجديده كما فعلنا منذ
بدايه الوفاء فاننا نعطي الاولويه للصحه
وسلامه العاملين في سلسله التوريد الخاصه
بنا
الوضع الصحي تعقد في الصين منذ منتصف
اكتوبر
المنطقه المحيطه بشركه الانتاج فوكس كون
اكبر مصنع
بعض العمال على الفرار من الموقع سيرا على
الاقدام لا يريدون الحجر في مكان عملهم
ولا المكوث في مكان يحتوي على مصابين 19
وفي محاوله يائسه لاعاده الانتاج الى
طبيعته كثافه فوكس كون من حمله التوظيف
واعلانات عن مضاعفه المكافات للعمال الذين
بقوا في المصنع
بعد ثلاث سنوات من اتباع الصين لسياسه
صارمه اعلنت شركه ابل الامريكيه العملاقه
في سبتمبر ايلول انها تريد التعاقد مع
الهند لانتاج هواتف ايفون